in nearly 20 years with Inside Edition
Lisa Guerrero has traveled the country
to investigate crimes scams and cold
cases
on the bike thieves we're going to going
to hide not just one but two GPS devices
in this brand new ebio
check my bike and sure enough there it
is hi Elizabeth I'm Lisa Guerrero with
Inside Edition we'd like to know if you
had an opportunity to watch the
documentary about you you've had 23 of
your tigers die do you think that you're
a responsible owner of tigers I damn
sure do
now Guerrero takes us inside her career
in her new Memoir Warrior my path to
being brave in the book she details the
nearly 10 years she spent as a sports
reporter and the scrutiny and harassment
she says she faced as a woman in the
industry Lisa Guerrero joins us right
now how are you doing
thank you for having me with those clips
yeah I keep watching those all day but
they're pretty fun right
Warrior yes yes why that title Guerrero
my last name Guerrero means warrior in
Spanish when I was little my mother was
diagnosed with lymphoma when I was eight
and she was 29 years old before she died
she was a Chilean immigrant before she
died she pulled me aside and she said
never forget Lisa your last name
Guerrero means warrior you were born to
fight she passed away a month later but
at eight years old I didn't know what to
do with that and what does that mean you
were born to fight and you know what
does what does the heritage mean what is
that what is that connection the warrior
in you and it wasn't until really
decades later that I discovered what I
was meant to do and that's to fight for
others and I'm doing that right now on
Inside Edition as an investigative
course victims Avenger a victim's
Avengers but you've been fighting
feathers for a long time starting with
your little brother your brother his
lunchbox was stolen you went and you
beat up the person and your dad had to
talk with you I love you your dad by the
way your dad had to talk with you
violence is not the answer and you said
well sometimes a strong right hook
actually works and you were a shy quiet
kid they called you Q-tip not a
compliment right but I want to talk
about your career as a sports person
another reason why I love your dad is
because
when you went through all of this
horrible things were said to you
horrible things were done to you and you
thought your career was over and your
dad said there's a whole part of the
country that doesn't even know this
about you and I I said yeah Dad that's
me I knew nothing about your sports life
Lisa so I'm so glad that you wrote this
book can you just give a brief Tick Tock
about the things that happened to you
that were so egregious that you look
back on it now and you go how did I
accept that after my mom died I
connected with my dad through the
language of sports so you knew your
stuff I knew my sports I wanted to be a
sports reporter I started at cbs2 in Los
Angeles as a local sports reporter and
there were very few women like me at the
time in the 90s and so I quickly went
from local to Regional to National but
what I noticed along the way was that I
was constantly being marginalized or
judged simply by what I looked like or
what the labels were that people put on
me back then former cheerleader model
bimbo
and and it was really difficult for me
to be able to to try to
push that those labels off of me I
absorbed that negativity like a sponge
back then but you had applied for a job
and you you're wearing a nice sports
outfit or a Blazer like everybody else
but then you go there and what do they
have for you to wear I had auditioned to
be a co-host of a sports trivia show
sports trivia game show I wore a suit I
got the job I showed up the day that I
was supposed to have my wardrobe fitting
and there was a line of leotards on a
hanger and they dressed me like a Zumba
instructor yeah yeah and at that point I
started what I believe is if you went
along with i i negotiated with it I said
okay if I do this I get a national show
and I can prove I know Sports and so
that was the dance that I that I did for
many years was I started to negotiate
and compromise so this book is really a
love letter and a cautionary tale yes to
young women about be careful be careful
what you choose to compromise about
yourself it's okay to be an NFL
cheerleader it's okay to be a model but
don't let people put you in that box you
choose who you are you take your pain
and you turn that into Power Lisa you
suffered a miscarriage on the air and
didn't say anything right because you
felt you had to do that why I was on
Monday night football at the time and I
was under a great deal of scrutiny I was
being criticized in the media I had a
boss that was verbally abusive to me and
I really let all that negativity
physically and emotionally damage me to
the point where late in the season I
started to have a miscarriage and
instead of immediately saying I need to
go to the hospital I need to leave I was
so worried about being fired
that I soldiered on I plastered a smile
on my face I went into the officials
bathroom I knew that I was having a
miscarriage and yet I was so embarrassed
about that and humiliated but I couldn't
tell anybody but today you sit here and
you say Brave everybody can be brave you
say every day we should do an act a
random act of Bravery yes exercise that
it's like a trained muscle that we all
have it we do if you commit a random act
of Bravery every day one small thing
that you don't think in the morning I
don't think I can do that one small
thing if you do that every day when you
really need to tap into that bravery
muscle you'll be able to do that that's
awesome
thank you so much thank you I appreciate
you Warrior goes on sale tomorrow and